we're asked to reflect this line across
the line y is equal to negative four so
you have this line right over here and
they actually give us all of these
transformation tools right over here
where we can translate rotate reflect
dilate or undo what we were about to do
so they want us to reflect this line
across Y is equal to negative four so
let's get the reflection tool out the
reflection tool so I clicked reflect and
let's let's make this equal let's make
this or let's make this line be y equals
negative four so let's see that would
look something y equals negative four so
we're going to reflect this line across
y equals negative fourth so let's
reflect it and there you have it we
reflected it across y equals negative
fourth and then they asked us to answer
some questions when a line is reflected
the image created is a line we know this
is true because the reflected image well
this the original image had zero
endpoints these are just two points on
the line they're not endpoints they're
not they're not defining the end of the
line if they were both endpoints would
be a line segment but this line keeps
going in both directions so we know this
is true because the reflected image has
zero endpoints and we got it right